let's talk about the number one best
home test
to determine
if you may have a hypothyroid condition
or not now the problem with
hypothyroidism
is that it's very very difficult
sometimes to figure out if you have a
hypothyroid problem because
let's say for example you have many of
the common symptoms but then you go get
a test it all comes out normal
like how can that happen
or let's say for example your test does
come out abnormal
let's say they say you have low thyroid
hormones you have a hypothyroid
condition yet you don't have very many
symptoms you're not overweight you don't
have this you don't have that so it can
be very very confusing so i want to
share with you
some very interesting things about the
thyroid that you probably have never
heard of
and what i'm doing is i'm summarizing
all of this great knowledge that i've
accumulated in working with tens of
thousands of people and that's one of
the advantages that i have
i was had a chance to spend 30 years in
practice to work with real live people
or as compared to other experts who
don't have the experience they basically
graduate and then they start teaching or
they start doing research
unfortunately right now it is difficult
to find
good
knowledge because when you do searches
on youtube or google
many times this great knowledge is
buried it's suppressed it's very
difficult to find
for example they have google health
right now which google owns youtube
and google health has recently partnered
with
various groups that consider
credible
health information
as
what most the experts agree on so their
definition of quality information is a
lot different than my definition of
quality information
so if at some point in the future you
cannot find
any of dr berg's information
realize i have an app all the videos
that are on youtube
are also on that app
okay so
so just remember that all right let me
get back on track number one
hashimoto's is behind 90
of all of the cases when you're talking
about a hypothyroid situation i mean
that's fascinating only 10
are caused by something else so this
autoimmune disorder hashimoto's is
extremely common and an autoimmune
condition is a condition where you have
antibodies that are attacking your own
thyroid and so one thing you really need
to know about and this is the most
important thing is that gluten okay
that's a protein in certain grains
especially wheat can mimic
certain things in your thyroid gland now
what does that mean what's the
significance of that that means if you
develop an allergy to gluten you will
also develop an allergy to your own
thyroid gland okay and this can set you
up for a
chronic inflammatory condition
of your thyroid gland and so if you have
a thyroid problem
you should completely and utterly avoid
gluten at all costs and just that right
there might give you a tremendous amount
of relief
with your thyroid condition the other
thing you need to know about hashimoto's
is that
a big problem of that is the conversion
from t4 to t3 now t4 is the inactive
version
of the thyroid hormone t3 is the active
version
and so
when we talk about three and four we're
talking about the number of iodine
molecules that are attached to that
thyroid gland so when you strip off an
iodine molecule it becomes activated and
everyone's talking about iodine for the
thyroid but for the conversion you need
selenium that's another trace mineral
selenium if you're not getting enough
selenium you're not going to be able to
make this conversion so selenium is a
very important trace mineral for the
thyroid and you can get it from sea calf
which also has iodine and a lot of other
nutrients for the thyroid gland the
other thing that you need to know is 80
of this conversion
happens through the liver and the
gallbladder so if there's damage with
the liver let's say you have a fatty
liver or you have hepatitis or you have
cirrhosis or you have your gallbladder
removed or you have a gallbladder
problem
that could be the reason why your
thyroid's not working so it could be
that you don't really have a primary
thyroid it's secondary to this other
problem and so you're doing all this
treatment you're on synthroid for years
and you don't really seem to ever get
better and this is why when sometimes
people take
purified bile salts
um their thyroid starts to work better
so because it's speeding up this
conversion now i said eighty percent of
the liver the gallbladder but the other
twenty percent occurs in your kidney now
if you're a diabetic okay
you probably have some weakness within
within the kidney and that could be the
reason why you have a thyroid problem
possibly but the point is that the
kidneys are responsible for 20 of the
conversion and the liver is responsible
for the 80 of the conversion but like i
said before it could also be a lack of
selenium oh and by the way one brazil
nut will give you all the selenium you
need for that day all right here's some
other things you need to know about the
thyroid and and these things i'm telling
you are the most
important things that you're probably
not going to find
when you do research you'll find a lot
of other information but it might not be
the most important information it could
be just
kind of trivial and so not all knowledge
has an equal
importance
some things are way more important
than others what i'm teaching you right
now is the important stuff i would say
probably the majority of hypothyroid
cases
are not primary hypothyroid cases
they're secondary to these other factors
that i'm talking about now but there's a
couple other points i want to mention
them about that number one
if your estrogen is too high if you're
estrogen dominant that could be the
reason why your thyroid is not working
so as estrogen goes up
your thyroid goes
down so that's another cause and so
women that have heavy periods that have
estrogen dominance
a lot of times have a thyroid problem
and so instead of treating the thyroid
they should be treating the estrogen
dominance or they just won't see the
results and another thing about the
thyroid if you have thyroid nodules that
is a classic iodine deficiency and
there's a very simple test to do to see
if you are deficient in iodine and i
will talk about that in a minute and the
classic symptoms of a hypothyroid
situation would be
you're cold
you're tired
your cholesterol is higher
you're depressed you have a puffy face
you have weight gain all over the body
equally
you're getting constipation
you have hair loss thinning of the hair
loss of eyebrows right here dry skin dry
hair
and you have brain fog other than that
you're perfectly fine so with all the
confusion how do you really know
you have a true hypothyroid situation
and it's not secondary to something else
well i'm going to show you a really
really cool test that you probably have
never heard about before but it's pretty
darn accurate especially if you
correlate it with some of these other
symptoms too which i just mentioned you
know i just released another video on
the
adrenal gland some real simple tests
that you can do to determine if you have
adrenal fatigue so my whole goal
is to give you things that you can do at
home to figure things out to potentially
prevent
the progression
of a certain problem from getting worse
because if you can catch it right in the
very beginning and then you can use
natural remedies
you can save yourself a lot of grief
before i tell you about this test i
wanted to share with you one of my
favorite words okay and that word is
proactive what is the definition of
proactive this is what it means
controlling a situation by causing
something to happen
rather than responding to it after it
has
happened
okay
so you're being proactive if you're
doing something to prevent a problem and
this definitely relates to an eating
plan which
i recommend of course the healthy
version of the ketogenic diet within a
minute fasting it's really wild to me of
some of the responses that
some people will give me when i tell
them to do this
this diet
they might say well
i don't have a weight problem so i don't
need to do any diet i don't need to
change my diet i don't have a weight
problem not fat
okay well i guess the only reason to
change a diet is because of weight what
about
your health or better yet i had someone
to tell me they can't do
the ketogenic diet because they're a
diabetic
and i'm like wow
wow
that is amazing i mean there is no diet
you should be doing other than that one
so anyway if you've been watching my
videos my whole goal is to give you the
important
knowledge so you can survive
better now this test that you're going
to do to determine if you have a
hypothyroid situation is called
waltman's sign okay it's an ankle reflex
test so you're going to be using a
reflex hammer if you don't have a reflex
hammer you can just use the
end of a butter knife or the end of a
screwdriver
or anything even like this because
you're going to be tapping
your achilles tendon okay
and there's a reflex in your achilles
and tendon that should cause you when
you tap it to do this it should kick in
and kick out it should just kind of like
do a little jerk like that just like if
you were to tap any reflex right here
and you would see this
this motion right here so you're going
to do this with the achilles tendon you
can actually do it with
both ankles okay
now with a true hypothyroid condition
what you're going to notice
with your foot
it's going to kick out okay when you tap
the achilles tendon but it's going to be
very very slow on the return
okay it's going to be it's going to
contract fast
but it's not going to reset fast
okay
very important because the muscles
involved
in
hypothyroidism
um can't relax as good
as
normal muscles even though it's really
the nervous system that's affecting the
muscles
the nerves and muscles are slower with a
hypo
thyroid condition
so we're going to be focusing on
the
reaction
after you tap
and it and it kicks
the the return back to rest or normal
okay that's what we're going to be
focusing on if it's slower than it
should be chances are you could have a
hypothyroid situation so very simply
maybe you kneel on your couch okay
and then you can tap the
achilles tendon
and it will jerk and then watch for the
rebound
if it's very very sluggish
on both ankles suspect a hypothyroid
situation
that is actually a pretty accurate
method of figuring out a true
hypothyroid situation so if it's normal
okay
then you need to look at some of these
other reasons for a thyroid problem
maybe you have a thyroid condition
that's secondary to something else now
you can also measure iodine like an
iodine patch which
only gives you information about iodine
deficiency and
like if you have hashimoto's which is 90
of the time
it might not be an issue with iodine but
it could be now to measure an iodine
deficiency you'll take the inside of
your upper arm or the thigh
and you'll take a little cotton ball
and you'll rub some iodine you can get
at the drugstore two percent
just rub it around in a circle about two
inches by two inches okay either on your
arm or your leg
and then you wait for about an hour
if it's still there after an hour
chances are you are deficient in iodine
it should be able to be absorbed into
the skin and you shouldn't see a yellow
stain okay so that's the iodine patch
test so the next video that you should
watch would be on
various food tips
for the thyroid gland i put them up
right here check them out
you